dès l'ouverture de la cérémonie le
président égyptien confie les clés de la
maison à son homologue sud-africain
après un an de présidence de l'union
africaine abdel fattah al-sisi passe le
témoin à cyril ramaphosa devant un
parterre de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de ministres et de
diplomates
le président sud africain a juste son
micro et fait rire la salle en donnant
la parole à lui-même une atmosphère
détendue qui a précédé un discours au
ton plus grave
cyril ramaphosa a profité de cette
tribune pour rejeter au nom de
l'organisation
le projet de donald trump visant à
mettre un terme au conflit israélo
palestinien
je voudrais dire quelque chose sur le
plan imaginé par les américains en
écoutant et en lisant tout ce qui a été
formulée à ce sujet ce projet me
rappeler une horrible histoire que nous
avons vécu en afrique du sud
il s'agit du régime de l'apartheid qui a
imposé un système de terres attribuées à
la population noire avec toute la
pression que cela comporte
avec pour thème je cite faire taire les
armes ce 33e sommet consacré aux
questions sécuritaires sur le continent
où l'on recense pas moins d'une
vingtaine de conflit armé en cours
la corne de l'afrique le sahel et le
bassin du lac tchad sont aujourd'hui en
guerre
une vraie guerre ou militaires et civils
meurent par dizaines presque toutes les
semaines des milliers d'enfants ont vu
leurs écoles fermées soit parce qu'elles
sont détruites soit parce que m et
écoliers ont été obligés de fuir les
pays de l'union africaine entendent
peser davantage dans la médiation des
conflits et la crise en libye et le
sujet qui suscite le plus l'attention un
dossier géré principalement par le nu il
nous faut aussi mettre terme au conflit
libyen
n'oublions pas que la crise en libye
tout comme l'urgence climatique a une
incidence majeure sur le sahel et au
delà
l'union africaine compte bien reprendre
le dossier du bien en main rapidement
elle a d'ores et déjà annoncé la tenue
d'un grand forum de réconciliation
un rendez vous qui pourrait avoir lieu
sur le continent parmi les propositions
qui pourraient être examinées pendant ce
forum
celle d'une mission visant à observer un
cessez-le-feu en libye
[Musique]